Pietro?
Welcome back everyone you did not see that coming
this is going to be my new Wandavision quicksilver
video a lot of you been asking what's going on
with this big twist thankfully the head writer
from the show and the producers have explained why
they did it this way so i'll explain what's going
on because this is huge that they did something
like this if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i'm doing videos
for all the Wandavision episodes and right after
the finale i'll start doing falcon and winter
soldier episodes as well obviously careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet but
i'm assuming that most of you if you're watching
this video you've already seen it but during
Wandavision episode 5 evan peters quicksilver
shows up from the fox x-men movies but seemingly
evan peters is playing mcu quicksilver and the
show presented it as if scarlet witch had recast
the role of her brother pietro formerly played
by aaron taylor johnson and of course it blew
everyone's minds we all expected some quicksilver
easter eggs on the show but this is like kevin
feige saying hold my beer i'll do you one better
and because evan peters quicksilver is also a
major character during episode six and we just got
an early preview of that there are all kinds of
theories about what his presence on the show means
because there's so many different things happening
in this scene right here not only do you have a
big x-men movies marvel mcu crossover but because
of the way her powers work and the fact that she's
an unreliable narrator because her mental state is
deteriorating before she just completely loses it
house of m style it's really hard to take this
at face value so it seems like there's something
darker also going on at the same time like is this
just a fake out and he'll wind up being a totally
different character what was their reason for
doing this other than just blowing up the internet
so a couple days after episode 5 was released the
showrunner and the head writer who actually wrote
these scenes explained what was going on and why
they did it this way she gave a lot of good quotes
so i'll just explain this as we go along and talk
about the easter eggs and how this all weaves into
the larger narrative but the head writer explained
that they always wanted to bring back quicksilver
from the very start of the show when they were
first conceiving of what it was going to be
because the series is all about telling the
story of scarlet witch's trauma and how she
deals with that the trauma of vision dying
during avengers infinity war her brother her
twin brother dying remember because they carefully
crafted that one scene i'm a twin i had a brother
like i haven't talked about him in a couple big
big movies and just the general trauma that she
experienced in her upbringing in sokovia
and then at the hands of baron von strucker
when her powers were unlocked by the mind stone
some of these things are still unfolding on the
show like we've seen trailer footage from future
episodes that we haven't actually seen appear
during the episodes yet the twins billy and tommy
wicken and speed the weird things they're doing
with the sitcom tropes in the house of m aspects
of the story her gradual descent to full-blown
mental breakdown losing her completely all those
things are in service of doing a deep dive on
wanda the truth of scarlet witch's character in a
way that the marvel movies have never done before
so regardless of which quicksilver we were
going to get he was going to come back so
that they could devote part of the story of
Wandavision to her dealing with what happened
to her brother dying in avengers age of ultron
like oh yeah it is weird that we haven't addressed
this in a big way before there was a scene where
billy and tommy asked her about having a brother
and she told them he's very far away and sometimes
that makes me sad notice how she didn't say that
he had died or he's dead and that makes me sad
she told them he's very far away because in this
moment up to this point so far she hasn't had the
opportunity to completely process her quicksilver
feelings about losing him and because she's also
controlling the house of them reality she's not
totally in control of her own mind like we talk
about her mental state deteriorating i'm fine
i'm fine in all those modern family looking scenes
there are a lot of things that happen on the show
her altering reality or creating things changing
things on the fly sometimes she changes things on
purpose like when you see her point at things like
she's doing the bewitch stuff in the first couple
of episodes like samantha then there are other
times on the show we've noticed where she changes
things and she didn't mean to do it or she wasn't
thinking about it consciously so a lot of what's
happening right now as she's slowly deteriorating
is things are happening around her subconsciously
she doesn't really understand how her cosmic
powers are affecting the reality of westview
like she says when evan peters quicksilver rings
the doorbell she didn't mean to do that she tells
vision i don't know how all of this started
talking about everything that's happening
inside this house of m reality she says she didn't
make the doorbell ring just to avoid the difficult
emotional conversation they were having i i
didn't do that i don't know what's going on
but that's kind of a lie she's not totally being
truthful she did make some of this happen her
subconscious willed it to happen because she spent
all afternoon thinking about quicksilver thinking
about death like the way that normal people in
real life try to avoid dealing with difficult
emotions difficult thoughts and then those
manifest in weird ways later on without you
completely realizing it so her mind is telling
her basically that she needs to deal with this
finally so quicksilver boom appears just not the
quicksilver you expected did not see that coming
i'm just going to read the quote that the head
writer gave when they were talking about this
big wtf twist she says the show is such a mind
scramble and because it's working on so many
levels and there are so many notions of what's
real and what's not in performance and casting
an audience and fandom we just thought it would
be the biggest thrill to bring evan peters over
to the marvel cinematic universe obviously taking
advantage of the fact that they have control of
the fox characters and legally they can do that
now then she says we thought how do we give him
this entrance and then enjoy that and then make
it crazy and we'd long had the idea of the trope
of the brother or the relative or whoever comes
to town and stirs things up with the family that
sitcom trope so she's talking about quicksilver
coming to the show to start some between scarlet
witch and vision which i think explains some of
the stuff we've seen in the trailers for episode
six like he's showing up to purposefully be a dick
because that's a bit of a sitcom trope and that's
why the way he performs some of these scenes that
he has here seems different from his fox x-men
quicksilver character and he also doesn't seem
like he's acting like the aaron taylor johnson
mcu quicksilver when that happened a lot of people
were just theorizing that maybe he was pretending
to be someone else but the way the writers
are explaining it no this is supposed to be
quicksilver and it's supposed to feel very wrong
something is supposed to feel not right about this
they said that evan peters was a huge comic book
fan and he was always up for the idea the minute
they pitched him on it so he was never fighting
them on getting paid more money or anything like
that he was always like hell yes i will show up
as quicksilver they said that the only notes that
kevin feige had about doing this is that there
had to be a reason for it and it had to make sense
they couldn't just do it just to do it as a twist
but part of the early idea for this was to do the
sitcom trope of the recasting like they recast
a character on a sitcom but then never address
it none of the other characters make reference to
the fact that suddenly the character that they've
known this whole time looks completely different
and maybe acts a little bit different too
and they wanted to do the most wtf version of
that possible like how can we make this as crazy
as possible well we'll do a big fox universe
x-men crossover with the mcu and like kevin
feige said it had to make sense the reason why it
makes sense is because scarlet witch isn't in her
right mind and has crazy cosmic level powers
of creation reality warping like she does in
the comics so a lot of what we're seeing play out
from her perspective is her imagination just being
manifested sometimes not completely on purpose
and obviously them recasting quicksilver is kind
of funny tv and movies have done this since the
dawn of time recasting actors they're two really
big marvel examples in the last 10 years just
a couple small indie movies nobody really saw
maybe you didn't see him mark ruffalo don cheadle
in avengers in iron man 2. kevin feige and marvel
recast both the hulk in war machine and even
though a lot of fans at the time thought it was
a bit strange in the moment like the first time we
saw the movies since then nobody's really paid it
that much mind like oh yeah there was a different
version of war machine in that first iron man film
there was that edward norton incredible hulk movie
fun fact too way back in the day mark ruffalo was
originally considered for the role of the hulk
before they cast edward norton in the first movie
but because edward norton at the time was just
a much bigger star they went with him so when it
came time to recast the hulk they just went back
to mark ruffalo because he was already really
close to the top of their list the war machine
recasting was a little bit different for roadie
it was mostly because terence howard just got into
a pay dispute with marvel wanting to be paid the
same amount of money as robert downey jr for all
the iron man sequels and marvel was like nope
not going to do that so like the writers say
there's like four or five different things that
are happening in this scene it's so meta it's a
bit of a commentary about what they've done in the
mcu so far it's more real-life crossover blending
the fox marvel universe with the mcu which we're
going to continue to see in the future when people
like deadpool ryan reynolds come back from the fox
movies in new mcu movies and it's also meant to
hype up the fact that scarlet witch is slowly kind
of losing control of what's happening around her
and she's an unreliable narrator you're meant to
not trust this ezreal like something is definitely
wrong here they also clarify that scarlet witch's
reaction when she first opens the door and her
eyes go all wide she also kind of can't believe
it and starts to sense that something's not
right like vision has been talking about for
the past couple of episodes but before this moment
she's just kept brushing past it rewinding things
she's been trying to avoid the truth this whole
time like she's been trying to drink her own
kool-aid believing the lies that she's fabricating
into reality with her powers but also at the same
time she's speaking the truth when she's talking
to vision saying that she doesn't understand how
any of this is happening or unfolding and the
reason for that is just because even scarlet
witch doesn't totally understand how powerful she
is and how her powers work the background cosmic
radiation the power of creation the power of the
infinity stones so just to be clear in the context
of the Wandavision series evan peters really is
meant to be the recast version of mcu quicksilver
but a lot of the way he looks and acts is the
result of scarlet witch's reality warping powers
in the role that she sort of cast for him the
role she forces him into with her abilities
remember how monica rambo talked about it they all
feel this overwhelming presence of scarlet witch's
mind pressing down on them forcing them into these
roles so essentially she's low level emceeing the
entire town the way she emceed all those guards
when she was going up against the sword agents
and as we've seen from the townspeople the only
time that they are able to break out of that
break out of her control is when something
distracts her some real wtf moment that shakes
her out of it for a second too then when the
writers say that wanda is also starting to finally
realize that something is really going wrong when
quicksilver shows up they're supposed to deal with
that more during episode six and like i said the
fact that he's acting really mean towards scarlet
witch and vision is on purpose it's meant to be a
sitcom trope like the super edgy brother comes in
to mix things up with the family on purpose
just to create drama for the sake of drama
but because this is marvel this is the mcu there's
obviously going to be a whole bunch of easter eggs
and they're all supposed to be wearing halloween
costume versions of their classic comic book
costumes i'm expecting a bunch of easter eggs
for classic quicksilver and a lot of people
have pointed out that he was kind of a dick in the
comics but according to the writers that's what's
really going on with this evan peters quicksilver
twist it's not them trying to do some crazy
mephisto thing or even something bigger so i would
just tune your theories accordingly but obviously
i'll be posting my full episode 6 video on friday
just like normal so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that but
now that the writers have explained what's really
going on with this character everyone post
all your new theories in the comments below
congratulations austin lawrence you're the
giveaway winner for my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details you can click here
for the two new falcon and winter soldier trailer
videos from the super bowl this past weekend there
are two different ones and you can click here
for that Wandavision episode 6 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!